hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
adventure mehr zusammen mit karl medien
zwar hält diese map zombie apokalypse
von hy
dann wird eine das schwarze
es ist eine sehr dunkle map deswegen die
helligkeit sehr hell gedreht wir spielen
das mit comment blogs nebelt wir haben
das passende texture pack drin und es
geht einfach nur zum die geschlachtet
richtig unheimlich solisten an die
zombie modus von black ops 2 wir müssen
die beiden draufgänger gibt dürfen
die leute retten weil die funktions led
werden
feindbild ist optional also wir müssen
ihn nicht finden können wir aber fein
regen die townhall das müssen wir machen
so das hat nur eine seite okay das heißt
wir müssen diesen dingsbums finden jetzt
baseballschläger lederstiefel und leder
harnisch medizin pakete wie viel hast du
ja ausgenommen 38
gut dann würde ich sagen kann ich direkt
anfangen ich hoffe dass meine dass meine
framerate aber nicht handeln doch können
wir und zwar verbietet
das setup also das letzte mal gesehen
hat hat der irgendwelche angemacht und
jetzt hat er glück ich die repariert
oder so und wir müssen sie jetzt finden
indem wir den becken lights folgen ist
etwas welche ist nichts hier sind auch
noch zombies erwarte ich töte dich um
einen gut wären pvp ausgemacht
vielleicht oder kommt es an
da kommt eine menge zombies ist unser
baseball bett diamant nicht wo wir hier
ein bisschen rum gucken wo die alle her
kam
ich weiß nicht ob wir noch etwas ist
bieten leid wir sollen den bieten leiter
folgen also ich würde sagen das ist
erstmal hier reingehen okay dass man
nach oben schauen was da so ist hier ist
nix nächstes einfach nur deko vielleicht
ist er immer noch eine kiste
also werden das aus beiden perspektiven
aufnehmen das heißt sie können es bei
ihm schauen und auch bei mir wenn bei
ihm zb ein spannendes passiert dann
könnt ihr einfach über schalten und
türen können auch bei beide videos
einfach gleichzeitig an machen was ich
empfehlen würde nach ich ja gerne so
together sachen die ich noch dass man
schauen wo bleibst du ich bin runter
gelaufen
wir müssen hier runter was macht man mit
dem schalter jetzt dann unter an
wir sollten eventuell nicht zu sprinten
glaube ich jetzt schon ein apfel john
cage
den rest lesen weil das irgendwie so in
dem links drin ist hier ist was immer
der rüstung müssen da roger meece
geschmissen
ein brocken baseball aspekt baseball
bett natürlich richtig abgehen
gut dann jedoch ohne das team richtig
das normal alle ausländischen schaffen
dann wie ich sein auf einfach mal
hierher dass man hier schauen sie
irgendwas alter schon krass
richtig gebaut ich meine es auch ein
pixel na ja okay das ist normal
er macht alles mit redstone der schläfe
auf redstone ja da kann man nicht hoch
da wo ich gerade hoch versuche darüber
da kann man nicht drüber
hier kann man auch nicht rein weil das
reisen türen sind aber es ist eigentlich
ganz geil dass hier sonne sonne roter
faden ist englisch schon verhandelt
man kann sich überall und ich möchte
mich noch kein ball rein irgendwie ich
weiß nicht
kellerkind sehen was hier sind so viele
sachen das ist ein ofen das ist nicht
das was wir schon jetzt ganz ganz viel
papier darin können paper passion papers
das nächste rennen extra schick ich gar
nichts ich checke auch nicht was was
soll hier sind zombies tod finden
ich würde sagen wir schon immer mehr
drin mehr geht es auch nicht
ok dann müssen wir runter dann muss es
ja land gehen lassen wo waren das jetzt
hier hoch erst mal weiter anbieten
bietet wahrscheinlich ja ich würde
kontrons vermieter darum ist jetzt
richtig ab jetzt richtig ab die
verfolgen
wir hoffen wieder hinterher er will bist
du 45 jetzt
aufpassen ganzen kreis viele zombies
pass auf dass intras viele zombies und
froh dass wir dies nicht angemacht am
pvp also richtig krass gelten jetzt
allerdings werde getötet
ich kenne seinen bogen oder sondern so
eine jury zeitbombe und die swisscom
nicht mit habe viele zu mir passen
auffassen auffassen von allen seiten
ich bin auch gleich tot aber er war ich
immer passiert
ok biskup versuchen die sachen ja cool
dann kann uns nichts passieren meister
kamera aber aufpassen trotzdem nicht
sterben nicht das team village oder
töten weil die verfolger den village
schon derbe gemacht irgendwie verfolgen
das soll mal auftreten nein nicht glaub
ich schon wieder alt ich bin mit 20 3
da mache ich mit da oben sind noch
klettere ich weiß nicht wie man goethe
nach schätzen 40 geöffnet
klickte startet generator 33
man mag oder die ganzen drauf drückt
einfach die ganze zeit anders sei okay
geklappt das hat sich gut bewegt ich
weiß nicht was jetzt passiert ist aber
okay gut
jetzt müsste es schon sehr geil gemacht
machete kneipe alter waffen gaslight bin
ich eine rose pfeile
ich schieße erstmal diese punkte zwei
jungs gewinnen
kommt jemand einen zombie aber schon
geil wie sich die welt dann auch so
verändert dass er dann jetzt wieder drin
steht also sehr sehr gemacht
downloadlink ezb findet ihr natürlich
immer alles in der beschreibung darauf
einer kiste kann man schön groß da
lassen ist schon eins haben wir jetzt
geschafft
dieter hecking die weiß ist wieder
optional eintritt müssen wir finden also
müssen rutschten und wir müssen generell
fixen also einmal kurz an die leute hier
ist jetzt nicht so verstanden haben die
diese stadt hier ist in großer gefahr
die zombies entwickeln sich und wissen
immer mehr wie man mit waffen umgeht und
da muss irgend einer dahinter stecken so
als als ganz großer kopf dieser ganzen
kampagne hier und wir müssen rot finden
und die engine raider fixen ich würde
sagen gehen hier noch jetzt abgesperrt
auch könnten einfach hier lang gehen
jetzt das sieht richtig aus sonst habe
ich glaub du kannst den wettkampf
dingsbums gehen und ich im nahkampf aber
die panik nicht kaputt machen
allerdings gebe ich dir gleich feierte
erst möglich japanischen machen krass
viel schaden
ok wat ich gebe jetzt feile da ich aber
bei 19
ach so ja wohl acht da einfach rein
warte ich muss das machen damit sich
mein leben ausfüllt ich habe angst es
ist dunkel dunkel bleibt erstmal ein
bisschen hinterher weil ich auch nur 46
viele warte ich würde sagen es sind ein
paar an ich hab keine waffen keine
pfeile gib mir die pfeile dann mache ich
erstmal auf entfernung ich sehe gar
nichts ich stehe neben dir erstmal
wieder abgesetzt sehr sehr wenig sehr in
zombie einen kleinen tumor in gott hier
geht es von mir getrennt
ok jetzt bist du hast du dir jetzt auch
runter und wieder platschen an ihr ist
keiner da war doch grad
hier war nicht gerade hier geht's zu
gott krass viele zombies und so gut
super gewappnet
zombies klar stimmt schon ich hasse
diese kleinen mein gott sind das viele
darunter durch dienst komische ich finde
wir können ein bisschen mehr rüstung
vertragen von denen ich sonst so was
alles lehrer ding sicher sein kann es
bei den händlern im eintauschen aber
richtig
okay gut ich bin unten auf entfernung
gehen ich habe immer noch keine feinde
der feier geben soll ja ich weiss
einfach hin
ich hab dir die hälfte gegeben
okay gut dass man erst mal die töten
hier drin sind wenn schon wieder level
25 m sodass er findet sich auch gar
nicht so ganz viel verrottetes fleisch
megawatt sind
warte ich erst mal ganz kurz was und
regenerieren so kommen erst mal kurz im
hoch- oder sind
triple
was erst mal da oben gucken auch hier
ist nichts da das nächste top wert